thank you for the invitation I'm going
to talk about joint work with mica
belkin and James boss were here with us
in the audience
I am a little bit surprised that I
haven't seen many jokes but the fact
that for the one hand we're in a
workshop on spectral methods and it's
happening precisely during Halloween
expected more there is an event going
going on lobsters halloween-themed the
tea or something like that right right
but maybe it everyone but I think that's
from the center not rough from our
worship isn't yes right out here no I
mean spectral halloween right anyways so
in this talk I'll in the first half I'll
talk about a new approach to the
multi-way spectral clustering and in the
second half I saw I will sort of
generalize the ideas of the first half
to introduce a new Olympic primitive
that we called hidden basis recovery
that encompasses some known approaches
and also present some new approaches to
well-known I got any problems such as
independent component analysis are not
talkin artists of the compositions
so I would start by reminding you
quickly about how spectral clustering
works and then tell you what's our new
while coding so what's spectral
clustering you take a graph and then you
construct the laplacian matrix of the
graph which is defined as the well i
mean there are several definitions if
you want to see the variations you can
go to a paper but for now i'm going to
already talked about this variation
which is you take the diagonal matrix
having the degrees of the notes so the
the matrix is indexed by the doubts of
the graph and then you subtract the
adjacency matrix and then you do
something with the bottom eigenvectors
of these matrix to get plastic let's
talk about this more precisely first in
the case of by clustering of a graph say
here is a graph with six nodes and here
i have the laplacian matrix and we think
of the by clustering problem one could
think of it as a certain graph
partitioning problem where I want to
minimize the number of edges going
across from one part to the app and the
advantage of thinking about the
laplacian matrix is that the objective
function of this problem can be written
as a quadratic form in terms of the
laplacian matrix what we have here of
course a torn obvious difficulty of this
problem is that it has a combinatorial
aspect it's a minimization problem over
minus 11 vectors so a natural way of
thinking about this and that's the basis
again of the metal is to relax the
integrality and then the problem becomes
a problem of minimizing a quadratic form
over the sphere which after thinking
about this say in terms of first order
condition it becomes an eigenvalue
problem on the laplacian matrix
so here is an example where i compute
the bottom second eigenvector of the
laplacian matrix and that gives me
numbers one number to every know the new
graph and one think of the clusters as
some sort of result of rounding the
entries of this vector right is the
entries we think of them as
corresponding 2-1 and the positive
entries to 1 and this gives you might
give us a bipartition so how does one
apply this to data well I have to think
say I start with a points in your playin
space and then I try to translate this
into a weighted graph by thinking of the
weights and similarities this is a
possible choice of a similarity a
function of the distance of the points
and then again as I said before I
construct the laplacian matrix compute
the bottom eigenvector and i use the
sign to partition
and for the by plastering problem this
works pretty well it has decent
theoretical guarantees however by
clustering is pretty limited because it
only gives you two clusters so the real
question is well what if you want more
than two then sort of obvious
generalization is to try to use several
of the bottom I ghen vectors of the
laplacian matrix if i want k clusters
then i will look at the bottom k
eigenvectors and then i think of these
eigenvectors are inducing a embedding of
the nodes of the graph in kale in RK the
embedding is a following I think of this
n-dimensional eigenvectors as column
vectors and then I look as this n by K
matrix and I use the rose as embedding
that switch for the end K dimensional
vectors and I'll tell you in a moment
why this makes sense and this embedding
is helpful for clustering but before I
tell you that well the idea is that
somehow some clustering structure will
emerge from just the similarities this
was just a graph with no necessarily not
necessarily any Oh Clayton structure and
then I one can for example apply some
variation of k-means in the embedded
space to try to recover these K clusters
I say try because now we see why this is
different from by clustering in k-means
as an algorithm is initialization
dependent and therefore is very hard to
prove anything about this come by in
albury embedding plus K means
however the motivation as a relaxation
of partition problem can still be stated
this k-way version so instead of k-means
we're proposing to do something
different as a second phase of the
better this is what we proposed so this
picture represents how the data could
look after we embedded and the proposed
approaches the following we're going to
define a function f on the K minus 1
dimensional sphere in RK and the
function will look as follows it will be
some sort of generalized moment of the
data so I think of taking my data points
X i phi of x i's the embedding i pick a
vector V a unit vector and I project the
points along this vector V so this gives
me n coordinates and then I just sum
them up but making them go through a
scalar function G so if G was like that
third power or something like that and
it would be indeed some sort of moment
of the data but I'm not telling you I'm
not restricting G to be a moment in
principle is any scalar function so this
is what F may look like they're so this
is like thinking of this as polar
coordinates in a way the claim is that
we will find conditions on G so that the
structure of local maximum of F recovers
the clusters so informally speaking the
local maximum of F which are points on
the sphere will be pointing at the
clusters this idea is new when applied
to this problem in a way but but we call
it contrasts function or abusing this
terminology sort of inspired by similar
ideas using the ICA literature where
there there are also directions I want
to find in Euclidean space and one can
pick scalar functions like here so that
when I max find a maximum of
function over the sphere given by the
scalar functions that finds the
directions that I care about so here are
the conditions on these scalar functions
that make the recovery possible so I'll
make a precise statement of this profit
the structure of local Maxima in a
moment but i will explain the conditions
first and for now I'm going to state the
conditions without quite telling you
where they come from well this is the
so-called hidden convexity that I handed
the title but that I will clarify later
the first condition and the main one is
that the function G composed with square
root of x is strictly convex and then
there is a second technical condition on
whether behavior of the derivative at
the origin here at example of functions
that satisfy these conditions maximum
minus the absolute value x to the p for
p greater than 2 e to the minus x
squared and the loegering of the
hyperbolic cosine this function has is
one of the standard contrasts using an
independent component analysis so that
when I'm mentioning it it's interesting
that we can prove things about it in
this context because in ica is some sort
of heuristic that works in practice but
nothing can be proven about it
so after one picks such a contrast
function what does the algorithm look
like with there are two options after
the expected the spectral embedding
either i do great in a sent to try to
find one local maximum or if i do it
repeatedly i can enumerate all of them
because we'll see in a moment we're not
just showing that local maxima
correspond to clusters in a one
directional way but is a one-to-one
correspondence so this function the
enumeration of local maxima is not an
intractable problem because there won't
be that making another alternative again
this depends on the structure of the
data would be to just maximize F over
the directions given by the data points
so you see this really two different
complexity depending on what parameters
you are working with
so here is an example of that at least
this makes sense in practice this first
example is on artificial data the data
are these three concentric rings from
which I construct a similarity graph and
then in turn a function f on the sphere
to be maximized and in the middle I have
the resulting clustering from the early
and this is representing the structure
of local maximum of F we see that two
clusters here correspond to red regions
regions of higher value and here is
another example on real world data is an
image image segmentation example the
objective of this problem is to somehow
partition the images into regions having
similar pixels there is no formal
definition of what the correct output to
this problem is because generally one
compares with segmentation done by
humans and that's what one considers the
ground truth particular well here we do
the segmentation on the graph of pixels
of each image right where the similarity
is defined as a function of adjacency of
pixels weighted by proximity and color
similarity and the contrast function is
minus the absolute value
so let me then switch to telling you why
this makes sense this imitation
procedure to recover the clusters there
will be two arguments one is properties
of spectral clustering sorry spectral
embedding itself this light and another
will be the hidden convexity I was
mentioning before so first what's about
what happens with spectral embedding
that makes this optimization procedure
meaningful so here is a claim that was
known before that if the graph had k
perfect clusters namely it was
partitioning 2k connected components
then the embedding takes a very special
form the endpoints are mapped overall to
just K orthogonal vectors where all
points from a given cluster arm up to a
single point that's the geometric
structure of the embedding in this
idealized case and one can think of
applying spectrally bedding to a more
general graph as some sort of
approximation to this case right so I'll
discuss later
what we can say about the birther case
now when one computes the spectral
embedding of course the corresponding
eigenvectors computed are not uniquely
defined because these are the bottom k
eigen vectors in the idealised case
these are the eigenvectors associated to
the zero eigenvalue so they are
ambiguous because there is only an eigen
subspace but nevertheless this geometry
of the embedding is preserve independent
of how which I ghen vectors you found
the only assumption is that the basis of
eigenvectors that you find is a portal
Norma
so here I'm being more precise about the
geometric structure in addition to being
orthogonal there is some control over
the length of these embedding vectors
the length is inversely proportional to
the number of points in every cluster so
we have this is some sort of weighted
embedded basis or two not orthogonal
basis
and
a key identity to understand the
behavior of the function f over the
sphere is to look first write it in
terms of the original point which I
already did before it's just this
generalized moment interpretation but
when you use this hidden basis aspect of
the spectral embedding then it also
takes the form here on the left from the
right namely is a weighted sum of G
evaluated at the basis embedding vectors
so here are more precise statements on
the structure of local Maxima in the
idealised case so let's see again the
question is which conditions on G are
sufficient and even hopefully necessary
to guarantee that the local Maxima of F
over this field are exactly these basis
vectors of the embedding up to
normalization so here I'm restating the
two conditions I had before one is some
certain strict convexity and the second
is a condition of the derivative of the
contrast so we shall the following first
that these conditions are sufficient
namely if both p1 p2 hold then the
normalized basis vectors will be a
complete enumeration of the local Maxima
of F so this is an if and only if
condition maybe the two sets go inside
the local maximum points to a clusters
and there are no additional local Maxima
side and more interestingly the
characterization is complete and we show
that these conditions are also necessary
so more specifically if property p1 the
strip convexity property does not hold
for G then there will be additional
local Maxima
and if p1 holds but p2 does not then one
of the directions pointing to the
clusters will not be a local maximum I
find that one can find such a precise
characterization quite unexpected
and the the particular case of spectral
clustering because technically the
claims I made before we're for any
function having this form now for
spectral clustering as I mentioned
before the weights have a special
structure here related to the size of
the clusters and in that case we can
show that p2 is not needed as a property
p1 in itself is enough so that the basis
vectors are a complete enumeration of
local magazine so now I will explain why
these claims are true and what is the
hidden convexity so the analysis of the
function happens by performing a simple
change of variable rather than thinking
of this function as being maximized over
the sphere I'm going to map it to the
standard simplex in RK how do you go
from a point on the sphere to a point on
the standard simplex you just square the
coordinates right and if you restrict
your search to the first ortant and this
is actually a by action but then the
structure of these function emerges when
you do that because you now I'm doing
maximization over a convex set the
standard simplex and the condition p 1
the G of square root of x is strictly
convex implies that now the function f
when I define it as being a function
over the simplex not over the sphere so
after the change of variable happens to
be then a strictly convex function
and up to the business of just
restricting yourself to the first Horton
this was a bijective transformation so
the structure of being a local maximum
in one setting is the same as being a
local maximum after or before the change
of variable and then if you remember
this may look a bit strange because I'm
doing maximization of a convex function
over a convex set it's not the usual
convex programming setting of course but
this is also although somewhat
understood in particular it is known
that for such a problem the maxima can
only local maxima and all your cool
occur at the vertices so that already
gives one side of the characterization
of what the local maxima are the second
part that every vertex isn't is going to
be a local maximum does not follow
immediately from this explanation but is
another requirement of this argument and
that would be the proof of the first
result
and the proof that there will be
additional local Maxima if you don't
have these conditions is just a matter
of constructing the maximum explicitly
and exploiting the lack of Street
convexity say which was property one
sorry one question yes so that inner
product can be negative like the vc's
one well in principle yes I removed it
and there it was an absolute value
before in earlier slides but here I
remove the absolute value because I am
taking the square root so so the
function G first of all is symmetric
even the function G is even and
therefore therefore it's enough to look
at what's happening in the first portent
either for the sphere or for the simplex
so that's why I eliminated the absolute
value in this slide but yeah there was
an absolute value before when I'm
actually optimizing like on his side so
the algorithm needs the absolute values
you like but in the analysis I don't
need it any other questions
so now I'm going to switch to the second
part of the talk which is to see a
brother picture of how this primitive of
recovering a hidden basis works and how
it actually show that in other problems
that are seemingly unrelated to spectral
class day so there will be other
examples that I announced before like I
see a independent component analysis so
here is a slightly more abstract way of
thinking about what I just said this is
the primitive there is a hidden
orthonormal basis in our k so k unit
vectors orthogonal vectors and this game
implicitly from data I'm going to encode
this data as well as the basis in what
we call a basis encoding function which
takes the form similar to what i was
saying before there are scalar functions
GI I pick a direction you a unit vector
i project the basis vectors on to you
and then i evaluate each projection by a
scalar function GI and then i add up all
of that so this is also some sort of
generalized moment and the problem is
given evaluation access to F and
possibly a few of its derivatives find
this hidden basis the vectors Zi
so here are my just restating the
example of spectral clustering that we
just saw in this language once more so
on one hand we have a fixed contrast
function G that I'm going to evaluate a
table projected point and I add up
overall points that's my function f and
buy properties of spectral clustering
this can also be written in this other
form when I were in the ideal case all
points in a single cluster got mapped to
a single basis vector right so the
particular form of GI the contrast in
the basis and quadratic function happens
to be some kind of weighted version of
the original contrast where I wait by
the number of points in every cluster
but essentially the picture is the same
as before I'm just renaming a few things
here is another example orthogonal
tensor decompositions so for example say
that T is a order for tensor n by N by N
by n which corresponds to a weighted
combination of run want answers all of
them coming from orthogonal vectors so
this CI vectors are orthogonal de forma
basis WI takes into account the date the
actual length may be different and then
the encoding function the basis
according function induced by this test
or decomposition problem is just
evaluating the tensor at you come I
akuma akuma you which after your right
is it just becomes this function here
summation of WI you not see I to the
fourth which is in the previous one
after you take us contrast the weights
times the fourth power
once you write that you can try to use
what I said before about hidden
convexity to think about why power
alliteration works for for the density
orthogonal tensor decomposition problem
so here is one way of thinking about it
the previous discussion would say that
there is a hidden convexity property
there because the contrast functions GI
when evaluated at roti are quadratic is
wi t square for the tensor decomposition
problem and this is a strictly convex
function therefore as in the hidden
convexity discussed for the spectral
clustering problem plus minus the hidden
basis vectors that set is a complete
enumeration of local Maxima of T of you
cumin you cumin cumin over the sphere
and in fact the power iteration the
tensor Powell iteration algorithm can be
reinterpreted in this sense a some
version of projected gradient ascent
with an automatic adaptive step size
so here is another example independent
component analysis that we have seen
before in other talks here so I'd remind
you what the problem is you are given
samples from a random vector n
dimensional random vector X D
dimensional random vector where X is a
linear image of another random vector s
also the dimensional and with the
property that the coordinates of s are
independent ace assumed to be a square
invertible matrix and the objective is
to recover the matrix a up to certain
inherent ambiguities of this problem
mainly it's not hard to see that you
cannot recover the sign of the columns
of a and you cannot recover the
permutation of the columns of it but
otherwise this is a solemn problem so
after a step that is standard in some
algorithms for ICA which is the
so-called whitening step or you also
think it is putting the vector X in
isotropic position by using second
moment information about X we can assume
that the matrix a is unitary so the
columns form an orthonormal basis rather
than the general case and then the
question is to again recover a but now
we know that it's only an orthonormal
matrix so its recovery of our
orthonormal basis or a rotation matrix
in that case by the ICA work and
standard choices of how to proceed after
this first step one can take as function
f the basis encoding function the fourth
cumulant of x along the direction you
after these transformations well in
general the fourth cumulant is just some
polynomial over the first four moments
but because i am in the isotropic case
so say i'm assuming that the covariance
of x is the identity
then the fourth cumulant takes this form
there's a fourth moment minus 3 so
something I can estimate from my data
without knowing the hidden basis of
course and one can show that by using
properties of cumulants it's expands
into this form of a basis encoding
function there are scalars which are the
cumulants of the SI random variables and
then the fourth power of coordinate of
view along the hidden basis for every
basis element so it's again some wait
times the fourth power in this case
so what do we show about this primitive
well first we propose an algorithm is
not I mean in the spectral clustering
case i talked about gradient descent and
that's fine when that works
and that's not so original maybe here
instead will propose an alternate
available in that we call great an
iteration term it's a fixed point
iteration of the gradient of the
function f so this is the iteration you
just start from a point on the sphere
and you make it go through the gradient
of F and then you normalize
so this island is an extension of tensor
poway iteration so if you think about
the salary for the special case of an
order for tents or equal sides with
power alliteration but now we are
generalizing to a setting where there is
no multi linear algebraic structure it's
just this function and coding a basis so
here's what I see that it generalizes
our iteration if f of you is the
evaluating a tensile at a point four
times for a for order for tensile then
tensor power iteration is where you
evaluate the tensor at three times the
point and then you normalize you iterate
is right well if you compute the
gradient of F that's exactly the same
iteration
and we have pretty good theoretical
guarantees on this algarin well
technically the album is as I described
it great alliteration it's more of a
practical algorithm and it would be hard
to prove that it can be used formally to
enumerate all hidden basis vectors
because for example you may get unlucky
with the starting point let's start at
the point that is unstable but a fixed
point or something like that so when we
are actually proving things especially
when we prove that this converges even
under noise we are proving it for a
reforming of the algorithm that is more
suitable for a theoretical analysis but
anyway the the first thing that we prove
is that for the pure weight in iteration
the set of stable fixed points is
exactly the vectors we are looking for
so plus minus the hidden basis vector
and then for the actual enumeration
problem possibly on the relative noise
we show that a variation of the
algorithm can enumerate all the hidden
basis vectors efficiently even if the
bases encoding function has been
perturbed so this answers a question
that you may have been having when I was
talking about spectral clustering that I
was only talking about the ideal case
and what happens when you perturb and
the at least we know that empirically
things will find because I showed you
those examples say for image
segmentation but I had when we did the
analysis of petrol rationing we did not
do a theoretical analysis analysis of
the perturbed case but now we have it
through the salary
and finally you may also be wondering
well what's the difference between
gradient iteration as an algorithm
versus running gradient descent one key
aspect that was already observed in some
of these special cases in particular
tensor power iteration and ica is that
when you do something like grade in
iteration you can achieve super linear
convergence so for example the method
based on the fourth cumulant can for ica
can be shown to have cubed convergence
even though it's only a method that uses
first order information and that's also
true in this case more generally we find
conditions which are like stronger
street convexity conditions that
guarantee that this first author metal
will have super linear convergence
specifically if the ARFF EG the contrast
function composed with the earth root of
t is convex then the convergence will be
of order r minus 1 so for example this
just immediately generalizes the result
for ica because racing to the 4th power
will allow you to take are here to be
for giving you cubic convergence
questions motivation right that can
introduce new local
pedigrees
ah
in general yes so but the theorem will
put assumptions on the perturbation so
that they don't happen so let me think
for a second how to say this well there
is a good interplay between how strictly
convex your contrast is which has to do
with how deep the maxima will be right
so the condition will say well you have
to be somewhat away from the quadratic
case which is the limit the limit of
three convexity right the function G
equals T Square when I do this
composition which square root will be
linear so it's not strictly convex but
anything of higher power will be
strictly convex like T cube so you have
to be away from the quadratic case first
of all and that's a cross-trainer g it's
like the magnitude of better ovation but
the most convex the most strictly convex
you wear or strongly convex the higher
the perturbation will be allowed
I haven't actually done the comparison
so I'm not so sure this is a right right
I that sounds very interesting though
yes
so here is another example that I'm not
going to describe in detail but it also
fits this model which is sort of
inspired by the work of Sue Ann Kigali
the parameter estimation for the
spherical gaussian mixture model I feel
though kind of obligated we did recently
in our estimation of parameters of
gaussian mixture models that's probably
interesting theory doing spectral
methods which is because spectrometers
are frequently used for this namely
dimensionality reduction the message is
that for the problem of gaussian mixture
model dimensionality reduction can be a
very bad idea and it's interesting
because many old algorithms for
estimation of parameters have as a
pre-processing step some sort of
dimensionality reduction or
dimensionality reduction happens
somewhere in the algorithm and what we
found is that the estimation of
parameters in love dimension is
genetically a hard problem it was
already known before by the work of a
boy turned violent that it was hard for
some instance but actually is not just
hard for some instances hard for genetic
instances so if you take for example you
can show if you take two sets of K
points that are going to play the roles
of means of two gaussian mixtures then
the sets of means while being different
and genetic one can choose gaussians to
put on top of them so that parameter
spaces are far because the means were
far but in l1 distance or total
variation distance these two mixtures
are very close which means that any
estimation would be very expensive say
if they are for dimension one they will
be a distance e to the minus K which
means that you will need a number of
samples exponentially k to distinguish
them and and that would be the only hope
of estimating the parameters correct so
instead in in our work as well as a
simultaneous work of Harry Carey at all
we shown that if you don't project and
you start with the problem that's in
high dimension then you can estimate the
parameters of at most a polynomial
number of gaussians in dimension D if if
you project or you start with a problem
loading national that's hard so is what
we call the blessing of dimensionality
this combination of a napper bond and a
lower bound in this forest particular
row
so in summary I presented a new
algorithm for multi-way spectral
clustering which generalizes to what we
could think of as an algorithmic
primitive hidden basis recovery where
data is encoded by functions
generalizing 10 source and I also
described an efficient algorithm
gradient iteration that has good
theoretical guarantees for this problem
particular I complete the nomination of
admissible contrast functions for the
special case of spectral class so if you
want to know more this is detailed in
three papers the spectral clustering
aspect is in the paper the hidden
convexity of spectral clustering which
is in the archive the blessing of
dimensionality is this other paper with
the others on Belkin Google and applause
the more the merrier the blessing of
dimensionality for learning large cows
and mixtures and finally the hidden
basis recovery problem and algorithmic
results in a paper that we are going to
post in the archive in a few days
learning a hint basis
measurements and are going to be
so let's stop here any questions village
but I say